did you guys I don't know if you saw
this yesterday betta O'Rourke apparently
inspires enthusiasm from from some
people too much enthusiasm I would say
this guy tweeted this take take a look
at this it's a picture of a woman and an
Beto and the woman is staring long and
longingly at Beto and he's got his arm
around her and the caption says I hope
some day that my wife looks at me the
way that this woman is looking at Beto
by the way this is my wife take it easy
man that's not you don't if you want
your wife to look at you like that first
of all this tweet ain't helping matter
so I'll put it that way
can you imagine liking a politician so
much that you would publicly insinuate
that your wife is more attracted to him
than to you can can you imagine liking
it I can't that's not I can't get that
into a politician I really can't
speaking of Beto I I've been I've been
wanting to mention this for a couple of
days on a more serious note because it's
very instructive Beto at a recent
campaign stop was asked about third
trimester abortion and the question
itself is great obviously asked by a
pro-lifer and it makes Beto
uncomfortable which is also great but
his answer is not so great so I want you
to watch this exchange are you for third
trimester abortions are you gonna
protect the lives of third trimester
babies because you know there's really
not a medical necessity for abortion
it's not a medical emergency
procedures typically third trimester
abortions take up to three days to have
so you would in that sense if there was
an unexceptional have to kill the baby
in that essence so are you for or
against third trimester abortions so the
question is about abortion and
reproductive rights and and my answer to
you is that that should be a decision
that the woman makes okay so he
obviously doesn't want anything to do
with the question which is why it's
fortunate for him that the media would
never ask him a question like that and
they're not probably they won't they're
not going to broach that subject again
whoever this was asking the question
clearly is not a member of the media at
least not the the liberal mainstream
media but ultimately he comes out in
support of third trimester abortions of
abortions of abortions that kill fully
developed viable infants shortly before
birth and the way the question was
framed made that clear you know the
woman was saying well when you've got
these abortions of babies that could
just be born you could deliver them via
c-section and they would survive there's
no reason to kill them first you could
end the pregnancy woman doesn't even
pregnant anymore but the baby doesn't
have to die I mean what should we do
about that and about us as well it's
it's the woman's choice
now if this question had been asked 15
years ago he probably could have gotten
away with saying something like well I
support a woman's right to choose
however there should be common-sense
regulations and we want it to be safe
legal and rare nobody likes abortion
sometimes it's necessary yada yada yada
he could have got away with dancing
around the question and but but
basically coming out against late term
abortions but that's not gonna fly
anymore on the left it won't fly in the
Democrat Party you cannot run for
president as a Democrat in modern
America if you don't support the killing
of viable healthy third trimester babies
you just you can't run if you don't hold
that position now if I were a Democrat
voter which it may surprise you to learn
I'm not but if I were that fact would
disturb me it would greatly distress me
to realize that lethal injections for
infants is now not just an accepted or
tolerated position but a required
position in the party that I belong to
and vote for and support now both
political parties have all political
parties have throughout history have had
people who I remember members of those
parties and they go too far to an
extreme on a certain issue one way or
another every political party has
decided to tolerate certain extreme or
uncouth positions because they don't
want to alienate that portion of the
base we all know that's the case is the
case in both parties these are the deals
with the devil that that all political
parties make but what we have to
understand here is that the Democrats
they're not just tolerating the
extremists in their rank who advocate
for abortion through all stages of
pregnancy that would be bad enough but
that's not what's happening here it's
much worse than that this for Democrats
is gospel now it is doctrine it's
something you have to support or risk
charges of heresy you you need to
support it it is a basic fundamental
mainstream this is like a starting point
now for Democrats is yeah well obviously
you have to be in favor of killing
babies in the third trimester that's
just that's just you know square one
that's a really disturbing thing now
speaking of heresy Elizabeth Warren did
a CNN Town Hall the other day and I
guess she was asked about her favorite
bible verse and this is interesting
because even though the Democratic Party
is the party of Satan and even though it
has embraced Satanism and it is embraced
infanticide
in all of these forms of just the most
the darkest most debauched evil you can
imagine even in spite of all that still
most Democrats feel the need to pretend
to be Christian we still haven't gotten
to the point yet where Democrats will
just be honest and say yeah I don't read
the favorite Bible verse I don't really
even talk about I don't read the Bible
have no idea I have no interest in that
now eventually we'll be at the bite I
think within the next maybe ten years
that's where we'll be that's where the
Democrats will be but they're not there
yet so when they're asked about their
favorite bible verse which is why even
though it's sort of a softball question
if you give that question to Republicans
now that's the kind of question that the
media that the CNN will never ask you
know Republicans never going to be asked
that kind of softball question on CNN
but for Democrats I actually like the
question because they are so awkward
about answering it as you see them try
to scramble like wait a second I can I
think of one Bible verse oh yeah
and so it's it's it's kind of funny to
see here was a Warren's answer to that
question I'm sure some of you a lot of
who you know this story you know this is
the one where the shepherd is dividing
the world into the sheep and the goats
and as we all know sheep are going to
heaven goats no they're not and the
Sheep asked him why us why us Lord why
did you pick us we look like those like
those guys and the shepherd the Lord
answers back by saying I was hungry and
you gave me food I was thirsty and you
gave me water I was in prison and youth
is and he visited me naked and you
clothed me and as much as ye have done
it unto one of these the least of five
brethren ye have done it unto me
and and what I hearing that is two
things that guide me every day
the first is there is God there is value
in every single thing every day
and the second is that we are called to
action is not about you had a good
thought and held on to it you sat back
and and we're just departed that you
know thought about good things it does
not say he just didn't hurt anybody in
that's good enough no it says she saw
something wrong you saw somebody who was
thirsty you saw somebody who was in
prison you saw their face you saw
somebody who was hungry and it moves you
to act it really is incredible the
cognitive dissonance warren ultimately
as she's kind of you'd said you could
tell she's sort of trying to come up
with something and ultimately though she
says that her favorite verse has to do
with the value of every single human
life and the obvious answer to that is
yes but what about the human life in the
womb which clearly you think does not
have value so there is this you see this
with democrats a lot that they and it
seemed you would think at first it seems
almost odd if you don't understand how
democrats operate it would seem odd to
you that they actually will jump on any
opportunity to extol the virtue of human
life and the value of human life you
would think that they would avoid
talking about that because they know
that millions of babies have been so
sixty million babies have been
slaughtered in the womb and they're
perfectly okay with that so you'd think
that they would try to avoid that
subject they would try to avoid the
subject of the value of human life
because the obvious follow-up question
is well what about all the babies in the
womb and then then they're going to have
to explain why
oh yeah well except not those but they
don't avoid talking about the value of
human life number one because
she's on CNN and she knows that she will
never get that follow-up question ever
but secondly I think this is just it's a
kind of intellectual moral defense
mechanism where you know if you support
the slaughter of millions of babies and
you hold such a de based awful position
on something well you don't want to
admit that to yourself like you can't
admit to yourself that you're the kind
of person who's okay with that so you
have to keep telling yourself that no no
I value them with human life I value
human life human life is special human
life is beautiful I think that yes I do
and so you see Democrats constantly
trying to convince themselves of that
constantly trying to ignore the the
massive pile of 60 million dead babies
that they supported and facilitated and
funded and cheered on as those babies
were slaughtered they're trying to
ignore that look over it
and insist that yes I value human life
it's really pathetic to see while we're
on the subject of satanic evil there's a
there's a new show on Hulu a show aptly
named shrill about an overweight
journalist woman who I guess has a lot
of sex and does other things it's
basically just a Lena Dunham show
without Lena Dunham but there there is
an episode of this show just released an
episode that was apparently produced
with the loving assistance of Planned
Parenthood where the main character goes
and has an abortion and afterwards
afterwards she she comes home and she
explains to her roommates
I guess she goes to bed and she wakes up
the next day at her roommate comes down
and asks her how are you feeling and she
says I feel great I feel wonderful and
then she explains that she feels good
because she made this decision own she
said I made it
this
session only for me it was something I
did just for me and then she says I feel
so effing powerful right now now this
really this struck me when I watch this
clip because this is literally what a
serial killer would say I mean I'm not
exaggerating that's what a serial killer
would say they kill because it feels
good and it makes them feel powerful
that that's why that that's exactly the
motivate the motivation behind serial
murder and there's also a real the other
thing that struck me about this is
there's a real morbid irony to a woman
claiming that she feels powerful after
paying someone likely a man $400 dollars
to kill her baby she was exploited this
is the opposite of power
she was exploited by this man and by
this clinic she paid them and then they
did this thing to her and to her baby
and she said I feel powerful but yet
again what you find with this just like
with the Democrats I know I value human
life and you have women that get
abortions they I see I feel great I feel
powerful
yet again it's they're trying to
convince themselves because of course
they know at the back of their mind when
it comes down to it they know the
opposite is the case and women who are
honest about it after getting abortions
know that the feeling is really one of
total powerlessness and certainly you're
not going to feel good after something
like that all right some some more video
I wanted to play for you I have a lot of
video clips today I think this
definitely breaks my my video clip
record this is something that's let me
see here sure I have the right thing
yeah this is
something that's been making its rounds
on social media in fact President Trump
tweeted it retweeted it last night it's
actually from a year two ago so but for
some reason it just got new life online
and it's worth talking about it shows an
enhanced pat-down of a child by the TSA
at I think it's DFW Airport and this kid
just for the backstory this kitty oh he
already went through the scanner and he
passed that test but he had I think a
laptop in his bag that he didn't he
didn't take out he really didn't realize
he was supposed to take it out so
because he had the laptop they decided
they need to pull him away and do this
pat-down it's pretty tough to watch but
but here it is
so this guy was very focused on the kids
waistband I don't know if you noticing
he kept going back to that really weird
you have to wonder did you really have
to grope the child for two straight
minutes in order to figure out that he's
not a terrorist
did it really not occur to you maybe
within I don't know 20 seconds that this
kids probably not a terrorist this is a
government agent groping a child because
the child is trying to board an airplane
that that is the crime that this child
committed now that's really not the kind
of thing that's supposed to happen in a
free country in any other situation okay
in any other situation you would have to
commit a crime or be suspected of a
crime to be subjected to a search that
lengthy and and intimate in fact the
Bill of Rights would seem to require
that you be reasonably suspected of a
crime in order to for your privacy to be
invaded to such an extent but is the
fact that you're boarding an airplane is
that evidence to justify reasonable
suspicion well let's think about it over
the past thirty years let's say over the
past thirty years I don't know how many
people have boarded airplanes or tried
to board airplanes in the United States
but it's certainly billions I mean over
thirty years billions of people in the
United States have boarded or attempted
to board an airplane how many of those
people were terrorists well again I
don't have the exact number I don't know
if anyone could produce that exact
number but I mean a couple dozen at most
including 9/11 basically a handful see
you've got billions verse a handful so
and how many of them have been
twelve-year-old white boys zero okay so
zero out of billions so again the
question is the fact that this kid is
going through security even though he's
got a laptop he is that
that it all meet the you know the burden
of reasonable suspicion that he might be
trying to come to commit a crime which
would then justify his privacy being
invaded to that extent which would then
justify a government agent reaching his
fingers down the kids pants I would say
no see that that's the problem with the
TSA we have a government agency setting
up shop in our airports and subjecting
every person who passes through to the
sorts of searches that we usually
reserved for inmates in a prison but it
can't be justified based on the idea
that there's some sort of epidemic of
terrorists trying to board airplanes
because guess what there's no epidemic
and there never was yes I'm aware of
9/11 I remember it well it was a
disastrous event obviously but that one
event does not translate into an
epidemic and at any rate what reason do
we have to assume that the government
can do a better job of thwarting the
next 9/11 they didn't fort the first one
I Got News for you it's the government's
fault that that was allowed to happen I
mean it's it's the default of the
terrorists and sambala and the ones who
committed the acts first and foremost
but in terms of the people responsible
for stopping like something like that
from happening it's the government that
should have stopped that and they didn't
and they had plenty of chances to it was
a failure of government I mean these
guys were the United States as you know
for years they were taking flying
lessons they were they were they were
planning this thing and the government
never stopped it um so this was a
failure of government this was not a
failure of private airport security
remember that though those guys they
took over an airplane with box cutters
well it would at the time it was not
illegal to take a box cutter on an
airplane because nobody thought that
anyone could take over an airplane with
with or it was not illegal to take a two
but take box cutters onto an airplane
because nobody thought that anyone would
be able to take over an airplane with
box cutter so the point is this was not
really a failure of airport security was
more a failure of government on many
different many different levels but then
what happens
government fails on 911 and the result
is that the government gets to take more
power and now gets to involve itself in
airport security and that really makes
no sense I'm not just saying that there
shouldn't be airport security obviously
there was airport security prior to 9/11
what I'm saying is there's no good
reason for the government to be in
charge of it and I don't see how they
have any constitutional right to take
charge of it even though they did by the
way
why just airports that's what I don't
understand you know why don't we have a
TSA at train stations and bus stations
and cruise ships shopping malls sports
stadiums churches etc those are all just
as likely if not more likely to be
targets of of terrorists why don't we
have TSA agents there the point is when
you consider the extremely small
likelihood that a terrorist is going to
be walking through an airport and it is
a very very the chances are very very
slim and that the statistics prove that
so if those slim chances can justify
creating this entire government agency
and having the government full take over
airports and and you know do all this if
it can justify that then you could all
say it would just as well be justified
anywhere else where people gather or
board public transportation or anything
else now I'm not saying that I want to
have TSA in all those other places but
if it can't be justified at the train
station or at a church or at a ball you
know at a stadium if it can't be
justified there then I don't see how you
justified it editor and an airport now I
go to you know football stadiums all the
time and you do have security but it's
not government security
all right uh what else last thing before
we get to emails a couple of days ago
let me play this for you a couple days
ago a university in Toronto Canada held
a vigil for the victims of the New
Zealand mosque shooting and some guy
decided to wear a maggot to the vigil
and then there were predictable results
watch this okay let me say that I I
think it's lame first of all to berate
people who wear the my a hat there have
been plenty of stories about people just
wearing the hat to the store or whatever
and then they're accosted by an angry
mob I think that that's stupid I also
think that people have the right to wear
whatever hat they want to wear so I you
know that that is definitely the case
but I also am NOT stupid
so I know and you know and everyone
knows we all know that the dude wore
that hat to that vigil in order to get a
reaction that's the only reason he wore
it we all know that there's just no way
that a person decided oh you know what
let me wear this trump hat to a Canadian
vigil for the victims of a racist white
mass shooter in New Zealand there's just
no way that a person innocently just
thought well you know yeah let me let me
see what what should I wear to that
vigil for the mosque shooting I'm in
Canada oh yeah a trump hat that's what I
should wear
it's not a political event it's not a
trump rally it's nothing like that
no need for political statements so that
guy worked for a reason he wore the Hat
because he's a troll and he wanted to
get exactly the kind of reaction he got
and I have no sympathy for the
of people who decide that vigils for
mass shooting victims are good places
for stunts like that but you know I saw
this video being passed around on on
Twitter mostly by conservatives who were
saying that oh look at those mean
leftist attacking that poor man oh he's
a martyr for so stop it already I'm so
tired of this stupid hat thing I really
am I mean aren't you tired of they had
I'm tired of the hat thing on but could
we just stop with the hat thing I'm so
sick of it yeah liberals overreact to
the Hat that's true but I'm also you got
these people who wear the stupid thing
because they know they're gonna get a
reaction and they want a reaction and
then they get the reaction that they
want and then they go on Twitter they go
on social be today I have a victim I'm a
martyr look at what happened I had no
idea that that was gonna happen and it
did doesn't mean people were yelling at
me I had no idea they were gonna yell at
me for wearing a Maggie had to a to a
Canadian vigil for the victims of a
racist white shooter right no I could no
clue that that would ever happen never
and I wore it and that's so terrible
look at me I'm a martyr and then you've
got a bunch of stupid conservatives who
who play I'll go feed right into it and
say oh my gosh that poor man that poor
poor man well you know I call them
stupid they're not stupid they know what
they're doing and that's what annoys me
about it if it was just stupidity I
wouldn't be as annoyed because people
can't help being stupid but all the
people aren't you know the the
conservatives who buy into this they
know what they're doing and so you know
when I was talking about this yesterday
on social media and there were a bunch
of conservatives who told me that well
how do you know you don't know that he
was trying to provoke a reaction it
could have just been you know he you
don't know that no that's not the story
here the story is those mean liberals
and I'm just thinking to myself come on
man you you you know that what you're
saying is totally bogus you know that
it's BS so why are you saying it it's
just
tired of the game playing I'm really
sick of it the bad faith demonstrations
the trolling the self martyrdom everyone
is constantly trying to take every
opportunity to get attention and the you
know be in a viral video and to provoke
a reaction and it's just the whole thing
not to mention do you really want I mean
that hat is is a politician's
merchandise which it's fine if you want
to wear it but is that really the thing
that we want to we want to make that our
symbol like that's our new cross or
something like that's the symbol we're
marching under that's the symbol we're
gonna martyr ourselves for I get into
altercations over is that is the
precedence hat really now there are
better symbols in that like you know a
flag I mean okay that's a symbol that is
worth fighting over and for a cross is a
symbol worth fighting over and for the
president's hat is not a symbol that I
think is worth any of this all right
um let's go to emails Matt wall show at
gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
this is from Josh she says hi Matt I
heard you say bass on your show today
when referring to the stringed
instrument but you pronounced it like
the fish bass just curious if this is a
regional pronunciation or if I and
everyone else is saying it wrong Josh I
got this email from like 20 people
claiming that I called a bass guitar a
bass guitar yesterday on my show that's
the claim that I'm getting from all
these people and I mean if I did that
that would certainly be embarrassing and
it would make me a total [ __ ] but I
think that you misheard me Josh I don't
you and all these other people I don't I
think that's fake news I didn't say that
in fact we'll check the two in fact no
we're not we're not gonna check the tape
well we don't need no reason to check it
I mean it's you don't need to go back
and see it let's just assume that I'm
not so stupid as to have
all they bass guitar a bass guitar I
mean come on
this is from Sarah hi Matt I love your
show
I happen to hear yesterday that a
baseball player Mike Trout staying on
the fish theme a baseball player got a
430 million dollar contract that's
almost half a billion dollars to play a
game
this seems obscene to me I'm all about
capitalism and free markets but isn't it
overboard and immoral for society to get
people this kind of money to play a game
what do you think yeah it's certainly a
nice payday Sarah I think we can agree
with that
I would clarify though that society is
not paying this individual 430 million
dollars to play a game the Los Angeles
Angels are paying him 430 million
dollars as far as being overboard well
you know keep something in mind here
first of all that money exists it's
there it's there for the taking it's
there because people are buying tickets
they're buying merchandise advertisers
are paying their TV contracts and so and
so it's just it's a very lucrative
business is professional sports there's
a lot of money there so someone has to
get the money should the owners keep all
of it because that's the only other
option here if we're not going to give
in professional baseball these kinds of
hundred million dollar contracts to the
to the players then all that means is
that the owners are keeping more for
themselves and I don't think that that's
anymore just another thing to remember
is that yeah these guys are playing a
game that's true but you know what most
of us are doing jobs that are not life
and death that are not strictly speaking
necessary to humanity but most of us
probably aren't bringing people the kind
of joy and camaraderie and everything
that they get from sports so it's more
than just a game in that way I think
that sports are I don't mean to be corny
about it but as I mentioned I go to
football games all the time
I'm big Ravens fan and so you you know I
go to a Ravens game I go to the stadium
and for at least for those three hours
right we're all just we're all there
we're just watching a game we're not
thinking about any of this other stuff
we're enjoying the game for the game's
sake and and we've got this kind of
camaraderie yeah it's a camaraderie over
a game fine so it doesn't mean a whole
lot but still we're all there and you
know you score touchdown and you're
given a high-five to everyone around you
don't even know these people but you're
all you got 70,000 people in state
you're all friends for for those three
hours and because you're all just
focused on this game and you're having a
fun time late and so I think that it's
it is something important that they're
providing I think as long as we don't go
overboard with it there are people who
become way too obsessed with sports and
their whole life is just watching sports
the only thing they care about and and I
think that that's you know they could
probably use a little bit more
moderation because there is more to life
than sports but as long as you can keep
it in proper perspective I think that
although it is a game as I said it is
still a valuable thing to people and
finally importantly the fact is that
professional athletes are the best in
the world at what they do they're the
best in the entire world and if you
could be the best in the world at
something even if it's not even if it's
just a game but if you can be the best
in the world at something at anything
then you'll probably be rich because of
it I mean you'll if you're the best and
if you have a talent that puts you above
everybody else on the planet
in that particular area then you can
probably parlay that into millions of
dollars so is it obscene no I don't
really think it is honestly this is from
Jake it says my four and a half year old
boy likes to play dolls house and
kitchen with his little sister he also
likes to play trucks dinosaurs blocks
and Batman with his little sister what
would the transgender intersectional
social justice delusional leftists have
to say about that thanks for another
great show you keep talking I'll keep
listening yeah well I don't know I guess
so what did so your
is really your daughter and your
daughter is really your son I guess is
what they would is what they would tell
you where as rational people would say
your son is just a normal boy and your
daughter is just a normal girl from Joe
says I listen to your criticism of the
Christian film genre I have to say I
agree with you 100% however when you
mention some of the good ones in the
genre you never mentioned the Scorsese
film silence which came out in 2016
featuring Liam Neeson Andrew Garfield
and Adam driver beyond being a great
Christian film I would say it was easily
one of the best movies of 2016 have you
seen it did you like it if you haven't
seen it I highly recommend it yeah I
know I didn't see the movie I read the
book and I really loved the book and I
was very moved by it up until the last
like 10 pages because I don't want to
give anything away spoiler alert but I
mean the books been out for 50 years or
something so I don't think it is a
spoiler I for me the maybe they changed
the ending for the movie but I don't
think they did for me it was all ruined
by the fact that F at the end after all
of that the priest apostasy zé's and
gives up his faith and then lives out
his life basically in peace and then
dies and so that's where the movie ends
and even that wouldn't be it wouldn't be
necessarily so bad because the fact is
people did a pasta sighs in the face of
persecution and so there's nothing wrong
with portraying that in a movie but the
book at least seems to endorse apostasy
because there's that very strange scene
towards the end of the book where the
Japanese authorities are trying to get
him to a pasta sighs and they're trying
to get him to stomp on a picture of
Jesus if I remember correctly and then
he has this vision where Jesus is
telling him yes stomp on it yes
you know deny your faith it's okay and
Jesus is encouraging him to do it and
then he does and then he basically faces
no repercussions lives out his faith and
marries a Japanese woman and so on I
don't know it's just a very
it was a great story a great reflection
on doubt and suffering and everything
and then it just goes off the rails and
so that's why that's my issue with it
from Leon says hi Matt listening to your
scutcheon of Christian movies I agree
with most of what you say but here's my
question why doesn't the Christian movie
industry produce more movies based on
the Bible I don't mean I don't mean
doing another Jesus movie I mean any of
the hundreds of other stories that
nobody has made into a film yet seems
like there's a lot of material there I
couldn't agree more I say this all the
time but here's the problem I don't
think the Christian movie industry
really has the talent available the
acting and writing talent or the money
to do justice to an epic biblical tale
now Hollywood has the talent and the
money to do a justice but they don't
have the interest or the theological
understanding to do a justice and and
that's why the Bible is not mined for
more stories even though as you say
there are so many great stories in the
Bible and any Bible movie will make a
gazillion dollars the box office so you
would think it's a no-brainer
but for some reason when it comes to
Bible movies you know we get a Jesus
movie every few years we get a Moses
movie every few decades we've gotten a
Noah movie and and that's kind of it's
like those are the stories when there
are so many other great stories that you
know I don't even think the Noah movie I
thought was pretty terrible but even if
you were more biblically faithful with
the know I just don't see how you make
that into a grade well I don't think
there's a lot of fodder there
necessarily for a great movie but there
are stories in the Bible a lot of them
that would make really interesting and
and and not just great movies for
Christians or for Jews but movies that I
think anyone could enjoy because they're
they're interesting stories but for the
reasons I just said I think Hollywood
stays away for it from it as a side note
I also feel the same way about I was
talking about this yesterday I feel the
same way about the Civil War
I mean there should be 10 civil war
movies every year there are so there are
just so many great stories so many epic
battles so many fascinating characters
so much drama and tragedy and intrigue
in the Civil War but Hollywood basically
leaves it alone doesn't touch it except
for a few you know civil war movies in
the 90s and then there every once in a
while will get a will get a movie that's
set in the Civil War era
but as far as an actual Civil War movie
no we get we get we get 600 World War 2
movies and many of them are great but I
mean there's just so much you could do
with just a straight civil war movie or
make a movie about the Battle of
Antietam you take any battle bull run I
mean you take any battle we've had a
Gettysburg movie but take any of these
battles a Chancellorsville I mean any of
these battles make it into a movie it
would be a great movie but they don't
want to do it
and we know the reason for that is that
political correctness won't allow it
it's the same reason we don't get Bible
movies political correctness and I think
Hollywood knows that you know if they
try to make a civil war movie and make
it historically accurate and make it
nuanced and mature and interesting well
then that's going to require that you
that you don't turn the Confederates
into into cartoon villains you actually
have to give them a nuanced thoughtful
treatment and also that's where a lot of
the really interesting characters are I
mean Stonewall Jackson I think is one of
those interesting men that the United
States has ever produced but so if
you're gonna make a movie you'd want to
capture those kinds of men in an
interesting way but if you do that then
you're gonna have the PC mob coming
after you and saying that you're you
know an apologist for slavery and yada
yada yada
so that's why they don't do it finally
this is from David hi Matt I appreciate
your segments about the Bible you seem
pretty knowledgeable in subject that's
an illusion I assure you there is one
biblical passage that I've recently
found kind of troubling the more I've
thought about it and I love to get your
take on it
Matthew 27 52 through
before I'm sure you know the story and
you know why some people struggle with
it so I won't waste your time explaining
that what are your thoughts on the
passage also as a related question do
you think it's okay for Christians to
struggle with biblical passages honestly
I would never say this out loud but I
just find this story and a few others in
the Bible hard to believe for a number
of reasons but I feel guilty for
thinking that I'm sure it's a spiritual
flaw in my part or lack of faith anyway
thanks for listening to me ramble of
your show
hi David let me answer your try to
answer your first or I'll do this in
reverse order so your second question
first yes it's okay for Christians to
struggle with the Bible no that doesn't
mean that there's anything wrong with
you it's not a spiritual weakness I
don't think in fact I'd say that maybe
the opposite is the case the people who
don't grapple with these texts who don't
confront the challenges they are the
spiritually and intellectually weak ones
for instance a while ago I was I
remember I was talking to somebody you
know kind of about this and I and I
mentioned the struggles I have with some
Old Testament passages especially the
ones where God orders the mass killings
of women and children and prescribed
slavery you know the I mean they're a
bunch they the scene where he sends
bears to maul forty-two children to
death because they made fun of a guy's
bald head I mean the mean seems like a
you know bit of an overreaction I mean
that's you know I think that's the
thought almost everyone has when they
read that passage right and so I was
expressing this and the person I was
talking to basically said well I don't
what's the problem I don't see well I've
never struggled with that what's the
problem you need to have more faith it's
you know it's in the Bible so it's okay
so what's the big deal but if you've
honestly never struggled with this kind
of stuff in the Old Testament then
either you haven't read it which i think
is likely for a lot of these people or
you have the intellectual curiosity of a
jar of mayonnaise because or you're not
being honest because you think that it's
shameful to admit your struggles the
is that anyone who seriously actually
reads the Bible and applies their brain
to it and really tries to understand
what they're reading anyone like that
will encounter the obstacles that you've
encountered David and that I've
encountered and you encounter it because
you're studying and you're trying to
understand it and you're taking it
seriously it's the people who cite but
no problem no I don't see what do you
mean what are you talking about I don't
see probably those are the people who
are not studying it and they're not
taking it seriously and so they say oh
it's well it's just my strong faith no
it's not strong faith is it's it's it's
just it's the opposite of that these
people don't even know their own
religion and and don't care to know it
and so I would say the fact that you're
grappling with this and that you would
even send an email like that in the
first place I mean most Christians David
they're not sitting around thinking
about Matthew 27 52 through 54 they
probably don't even know what it says
never even just they don't think about
it the fact that you're sitting there
thinking about it is a really good sign
and it says something about you know
your spiritual and intellectual maturity
so okay Matthew 27 52 Thor 54 says and
when Jesus had cried out again in a loud
voice he gave up his spirit and that
moment the curtain of the temple was
torn in two from top to bottom the earth
shook and rocks split the tombs broke
open and the bodies of many holy people
who had died were raised to life they
came out of the tombs and after Jesus's
resurrection they went into the holy
city and appeared to many people when
the centaurian and those with him
regarding Jesus
okay well that part we don't have a
problem with so it's really 52 to 50 52
and 53 are the issues here the tombs
broke open and the bodies of many holy
people who had died were raised to life
they came out of the tombs and after
Jesus's resurrection they went into the
holy city and appeared to many people
yeah after reading that email from you
yesterday I was talking about this on
Twitter and I was saying how I also have
scratched my head over this passage it
is a tough one but again it's only tough
when you think about it if you don't
think about it then there's no problem
there's never any problem with anything
in life if you don't think about it but
after thinking the way I see it the two
issues that arise our first theological
so this says that a whole bunch of holy
people from the from the past we assume
Old Testament Saints were raised from
the dead
immediately after the crucifixion that's
what it says they didn't go into the
town until after the resurrection so
says Matthew but they were raised after
the crucifixion and this is significant
because first of all what the heck did
they do for those two days it says that
they came out of their tomb they didn't
go into the holy city until two days so
what were they doing in between is an
interesting question but more
importantly theologically how does this
work because Paul says in Corinthians I
think it is that Jesus is the
firstfruits of the resurrection well
wouldn't this story make the the Old
Testament Saints the firstfruits of the
resurrection because they according to
the text they were raised first and
anyway doesn't it kind of distract in
some ways from the miracle of the
resurrection if Jesus's resurrection was
just one of dozens of resurrections that
weekend it was it was the last in a
series of resurrections apparently
according to according to Matthew so
that's the theological challenge that
the historical challenge is that this
would be a momentous occasion I mean
many tombs are breaking open and many
people are coming to life many people
are seeing them walking around the city
yet no other gospel writer noticed this
apparently not one of them mention it no
writer of any epistle mentions it no
historian of that time mentions it or
has even heard of it
it just seems incredible that every
gospel writer would make room to mention
for instance Jesus cursing a fig tree
yet only one takes the time to mention
that hey by the way there were a bunch
of resurrected dead people walking
around Jerusalem you know it is as you
say hard to believe in some ways so what
can we do with the passage well over the
years Christian scholars have tried a
few different moves here the first is
well not the first but there are some
who have tried to interpret it in
metaphorically and have said well maybe
this was kind of a literary device that
Matthew was using that but I'm okay with
interpreting things metaphorically if
the text supports that interpretation
but the text does not support that
because why would Matthew drop this
weird metaphorical narrative right into
the middle of the crucifixion and
resurrection story about Jesus that just
makes no sense at all
so I think you got to put that to the
side the other thing people have
suggested is that maybe the text was
added in later I guess there is
potentially some textual evidence that
maybe that happened I don't really know
what the evidence is exactly I do know
that this story in Matthew appears in
every complete manuscript of Matthew
that we have so if there was if there
were a few manuscripts of Matthew from
way back a long time ago that didn't
have that story then you could start to
think that yeah maybe this was added in
later and we do know that that did
happen the the long ending of mark mark
16 9 through 20 whatever was is we know
was added in later the original Gospel
of Mark ends with the women fleeing the
tomb and telling no one and that's the
end and and and the original or not the
original but the earliest manuscripts of
mark that's how it ends the later
manuscripts all of a sudden have this
next part of that ending where it says
that Jesus appeared and and he told the
disciples that they could drink poison
and handle snakes and not be killed but
it pretty much everyone knows that
someone later on added that in which you
know someone should probably let the
pent the Pentecostal snake handlers know
about that because those people for
years I've been handling snakes and
getting bit by rattlesnakes and dying
because they didn't realize that that
story is not original to the gospel so
there's that all the story about the
woman caught in adultery and John early
manuscripts of John don't have that
story which doesn't mean that the store
isn't true it could have been oral
tradition that was passed down and then
added in by a scribe later on there are
plenty of scholars who think that's the
case but the point is it's not crazy to
think that maybe something like that is
going on with Matthew maybe it's
possible the other option of course is
that it happened exactly as Matthew says
it happened that doesn't answer why no
one else noticed it it doesn't solve the
theological difficulties that seem to be
raised here but maybe that's beyond our
understanding so what would I suggest I
would say keep grappling with it study
it think about it pray about it and if
you come to a better conclusion than
what I just rambled off which wouldn't
be hard to do then send me an email let
me know and maybe maybe teach me
something about it the more you think
about it and study it but I would
definitely pursue it and don't be afraid
of it and don't feel shamed and don't
feel like oh I you know I I should I'm
being too critical about this passage I
should just accept it
[Music]
no because I don't think it's I don't
think critical is exactly what you're
doing here I think it's more inquisitive
and it's good to be inquisitive we
should be alright we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed